I'm very excited about this because the
best videos on YouTube are from Greg
Sadler and I think every one of my
students has probably watched a hundred
of your videos so um uh Greg is an
amazing philosopher and he's gonna uh be
presenting on from the cosmos to cracks
and bread things of Beauty for the
stoics and um he is former editor of
stoicism today teaches at the Milwaukee
Institute of Art and Design produces
those amazing uh philosophy videos on
his YouTube channel co-hosts the wisdom
for Life radio show and is a certified
philosophical counselor uh there's more
about him in the conference program so
please look at that after this uh
wonderful talk thanks Greg well thanks
so much that's a very nice introduction
and um my talk you could say is a little
less ambitious perhaps than almost
everyone that I've heard so far um and
and it's just looking at types of
matters that stoics describe as
beautiful and obviously if you wanted to
be comprehensive in this we need like a
whole seminar because they say so many
things about beauty and so many things
are beautiful so we're just going to
look at a selection of examples drawn
from the three stoic thinkers that I
think almost everybody is the most
familiar with which would be Sena and
epicus and Marcus
Aurelius and we're looking at examples
that are coming directly from their text
um I've put them into kind of an order
and hopefully it's one that has a good
flow and makes sense for people so we're
we're doing a little bit of an itinerary
here and I'll just note very briefly uh
several times terminology has come up
almost all of the examples that we're
looking at in epicus and Marcus Aurelius
as Greek are using the word colog
there's a few where that's not the case
case and then senas tend to be um P
Beauty beautiful you know um and so
these are the the things that we're
going to be looking at and the general
plan is to begin with some common
instances and and features of beautiful
things and then widen our scope as far
as it can possibly go to the entire
Cosmos itself and then descend through
US human beings and get down to really
humble and seemingly un beauutiful
things and think about what the stoics
have to tell us about them and you know
what we can do at the end is think about
how we can have good or bad or wise or
foolish responses to Beauty something
that we've already had a lot of
discussion of already including in the
last
presentation and we can call out some
guidelines which again I think is
something we've been hearing about a
good bit already about how we can
properly and positively appreciate
beautiful items without getting sucked
into let's call it the seductive side of
I won't say bad Beauty but you know more
problematic uh instances so there's
there's two passages i' I'd really like
to start with and one of these is from
Marcus aelius in meditations book four
he says beautiful things of any kind are
beautiful in themselves and sufficient
to thems eles praise is extraneous the
object of Praise remains what it was no
better no worse this applies I think
even to beautiful things in ordinary
life physical objects artworks does
anything genuinely beautiful need
supplementing no more than Justice does
or truth or kindness or humility are any
of those improved by being praised or
damaged by attempt is an emerald
suddenly flawed if no one admires it or
gold or Ivory or purple Liars knives
flowers bushes and so what we've got
here are references to beautiful things
in what he calls um ordinary or we could
say even common life um Quon the most
common sorts of things things that were
all accustomed to calling beautiful and
so you know he talks about emeralds and
other precious things now you know
that's changed culturally over time not
too many of us are walking around with
gold or emeralds or anything like that
and we can reproduce some of these
things uh by industrial processes so
perhaps their value has come down a bit
but you know U fine works of
craftsmanship you know like a great
musical instrument or or a knife or pick
whatever else you want we go into
people's houses and we talk about the
moldings as being beautiful or uh you
know lands escaping Gardens all of these
sorts of organic things that we look at
we might think about beautiful animals
as well and notice the point that he's
making here all of these are beautiful
in themselves they're sufficient in
themselves whether we praise them or
show contempt for them or just ignore
them entirely so as many of the speakers
have noted Beauty for the stoics is
something that's that's real it's out
there it's available to to us even if we
don't necessarily have the right kind of
subjective responses to them and that
would be the praising or grasping it um
and notice as well that there's a
analogy that's being drawn here with
Justice with truth with kindness or
better put Goodwill anoa and shame or
humility idos these moral qualities that
we're looking for in in people so that's
a great stage Setter and then sen adds
something that I think is really good to
remind ourselves of and we're going to
talk about this a little bit more in the
end in letter 76 he says that sometimes
from an extremely beautiful object one
experiences great joy even in a tiny
space of time so out of something that
is really striking us we have gaudium
joy which is one of the good emotions
right uh for for stoics this is a proper
affective response to things and notice
that he says even if just for a short
time
tempori in Latin and I think that's a
great reminder we don't always have to
be on when it comes to the perception of
beauty sometimes it's enough just to
have experienced it for a short period
and then we can remember it over time so
let's uh zoom out and think in terms of
the biggest object we could possibly
take in the entire world the entire
universe and this is not a uniquely
stoic Thing by any means right uh it's
other philosophers before the stoics are
looking up at the heavens or looking at
the Earth and saying holy crap is this
beautiful this is amazing let's take
this in and it's not just philosophers
it's it's people of all walks of life
who are grasping this and you know we
can look at uh the the sky we can look
at the landscape we can look at physical
processes and and find something there
and we can ask ourselves okay well what
makes the world or the universe
beautiful and you know just pause for a
moment and think about your own
experiences of natural beauty what did
they Encompass certainly there was an
aspect of the senses taking things in we
never see the whole universe we never
even see the entire landscape right uh
in part because our eyes are right in
the front of our head I suppose a horse
probably takes in a little bit more than
we do because they're a prey creature
rather than a predator creature like
ourselves um but they don't take in
everything either so we're extending
ourselves out into the universe through
our minds and we're we're imagining
something uh the force of Impressions or
appearances Fantasia is is part of
Beauty for this and what are the stoics
actually
seeing so I'm going to have a little
play on words here the Greek word for
universe is Kosmos that's also the Greek
word for order and proportion and
Arrangement so we can say that it's
actually the cosmos of the cosmos that
is being grasped both through our senses
and our imagination and our
rationality and it's also that we're
grasping um something like a Divine
rationality at work and this this could
raise some problems for modern stoics
who think that the universe doesn't
contain any elements of that and we can
talk about that a bit later certainly
for senica certainly for epicas
certainly for Marcus aelius that was
part of it so I've got two passages here
from senica that I want to put before
you but you know we could easily bring
up similar passages from epitus or
Marcus or relias so if You' if you've
ever read senica's letter 65 which I
highly advise that you do you know he's
talking about Plato and Aristotle and
their notion of causes there and he
brings them together in a beautiful
harmonization and say then says that
they've gotten things wrong and here's
the stoic point of view on it you know
typical Sonica there he tells us that
God made this wonderful full universe
and he did so by using a model a
platonic form essentially an Exemplar
and he says the model According to which
God deos made such a vast and supremely
beautiful piece of work namely the
entire universe so for senica the entire
Cosmos is something that is beautiful
and it's modeled after something even
further even deeper a an an idea in the
Divine mind um in on benefits sonaka and
he says things like this in many places
clarifies uh even further the gods gave
us the second rank in this supremely
beautiful home and put us in charge of
the earth and this is a typical uh
ancient stoic point of view rational
beings are in charge of things we're
sort of like God's deputies so we better
not screw it up of course and we get to
apprehend this amazing beautiful Cosmos
that we we exist in that we have a a job
in so here we can start thinking about
us human beings and we have multiple and
complex and interconnecting parts to
play in relation to Beauty one of these
is that we are creators and producers of
beauty we produce things that we
consider to be beautiful
when we work with materials that we
consider precious right setting the
emerald in the gold necklace oh that's
that's nice right make it maybe we make
a a beautiful gold statue of uh senica
we could do that as well although you
know that should be pretty indifferent
from a stoic perspective um and we also
produce beautiful items of usefulness or
attractiveness like liars not so much
today more guitars pianos things like
that or um you know knives and other
implements your KitchenAid mixer if it's
welld designed could be an object of
beauty or through what we do with the
physical world engaging in gardening and
landscape and Arrangement but we're also
participants in the beauty of the entire
Cosmos that we noted earlier by being
part of it by taking up our parts uh as
as rational beings within it as Not Mere
animals right but as something that has
a greater purpose and by appreciating
this universe as well another term for
that is witnessing or understanding
right epicus tells us that um we human
beings don't merely take in appearances
and and you know grasp them and respond
to them we understand them and this is
part of our relation to the the Divine
ordering of the
universe senca in letter 115 says that
if we could consider the mind of a great
person oh what a beautiful sight we
would see we would see that beautiful
sight and by that he means virtue even
though it may be covered with dirt now
this is a a recent translation the Latin
for that Isam
sordidum now sordido Grime right kind of
scum and and things like that so even
though we don't see the the virtue you
know untarnished unblemished we can
still see it there and now notice
there's also an if there as well
obviously we can't open up somebody's
head and peer inside and see The Virtue
shining in there but we we do see it
through what people do as we'll talk
about in just a moment um Sena in on
benefits also says something really
quite remarkable the power of the
honorable the honom the intrinsically
valuable to attract the minds of human
beings is immense its beauty floods our
minds and sweeps us along enchanted with
Wonder at its Brilliance and Splendor
the most beautiful things are in fact
often accompanied by a host of Added
Attractions but it is beauty that leads
and the attractions follow along so you
know there's many different beautiful
things and when it comes to people that
we find attract
you know we can find their bodies
attractive we can find their sense of
humor great or all sorts of other things
like that but it's really we talk about
inner beauty which shows itself
externally that we can be amazed by and
dazzled by and attracted to or even
sometimes Sena doesn't talk about this
here pained by when we find that we
ourselves don't measure up to those who
we emulate in on shortness of life
another thing that senica says is really
quite cool we're led by the work of
others into the presence of the most
beautiful Treasures which have been
pulled from darkness and brought to
light now what are these most beautiful
Treasures they are the words the thought
the the lives being offered to us of
people long gone the possibility of a
relationship with ancient thinkers who
can actually give us as senica will say
more life and a beautiful life on on
that that way so notice that beauty
understood in this sense in other human
beings has the capacity to motivate us
it can jar it can rearrange it can fit
into our motivational structures it can
give us pleasure it can give us joy it
can provoke desire and not all desire is
going to be bad in relation to Beauty we
should desire some of the types of
beauty that are out there it can lead to
emulation now when we think about
ourselves because we're human beings as
well you know we don't know ourselves
perfectly we're all a little bit of a
mystery to ourselves uh so long as we're
not the sage and you know if anybody is
go ahead and chime in and let us know
because it'd be kind of cool to meet a
sage but I'm not gonna hold out too much
hope for that here um we do have a
different kind of access to ourselves
than we do to other people people right
uh we can't peer inside our own heads
but we we know what's going on in there
a lot of the time and so we can say well
what makes us genuinely
beautiful as opposed to the things that
are beautiful in our bodies or in our
possessions and we might want to recall
enidan 6 there there's a really funny
passage there epicus is going to say you
know if a horse wanted to get worked up
literally uh elated at by R menos in in
Greek because it it realized that it's
beautiful which I suppose could happen
it doesn't happen all that often um but
if a horse was gonna like you know pin
around and act as if it's really a big
deal that's fine right that's a horse
thing but for you to be elated because
you own a beautiful horse that's just
ridiculous the horse isn't you that
beauty doesn't belong to you at all even
if you have like a title to it and so he
says what is us there and and here he
says one thing that sometimes I think
gets people a bit confused when they
only focus in on passages like that use
of appearances theis
fantas that's not all that is up to us
that's not everything that we do but
that's a really important thing and this
actually addresses a lot of the
questions that people are asking about
the use of the indifference or our
relation to them um many of them are are
indifferent right and that that is up to
us and that is part of how we become
beautiful in discourses 31 epicus is
going to give us a lot you know more
let's say focused teaching about this
and he's talking about the context of
what makes a person beautiful and he
begins by talking about dogs and horses
right what makes those animals beautiful
and he says it will be correct to
pronounce each of them beautiful so far
as it is developed suitably to its own
nature and you know we can talk about
this in terms of many of the things that
people have brought up proportion
function all of those sorts of things I
just as a digression there is a
beautiful two-year-old cat that I was uh
hanging out with yesterday at a cat
shelter and um she's beautiful in a
sense because she is just a brute she's
super strong super fast um very dominant
when it comes to other cats loves to
play right well that's the way a cat
ought to be at that age right um and we
could go on and on and talk about all
sorts of other kinds of animals as well
now what about us we're not dogs or cats
or horses or any of those sorts of
things so he's talking to a guy who
comes into his school and he's a little
bit too dressed up a little bit too put
together and he says if you make
yourself such a
quality you know you will make yourself
beautiful but if you neglect those
things even though you use every
contrivance to appear beautiful you must
necessarily be deformed for you what are
you you are not flesh and hair but your
faculty of choice your PR racist and if
you take care to have this become
beautiful well then you're beautiful
because that's what you truly are and so
if we want to be beautiful we have to
think about our rational and social
nature about the virtues about our
character about the use of appearances
and indifference and about our
relationships and roles our connections
to other people and notice going back to
another theme that came up at the very
beginning of this conference these
things are up to us these are within the
scope of our whatever you want to call
it control Power business the epon right
um hmon rather
um
so notice that that there's
interconnections here we haven't just
started with the cosmos then we got
Cosmic Beauty and then the beauty of
other people then our own Beauty these
are all interconnected with each other
right we take part in society we take
part in a cosmos as rational beings and
that means developing the virtues that
means making beautiful choices that
means sometimes also finding the spots
of ugliness within ourselves
and looking at those and figuring out
how we're going to address those and now
we get to things that might be a little
bit ugly or have the potential for that
Marcus aelius in meditations 3.2 a
passage that we've already talked about
a little bit um we should remember that
even Nature's inadvertence has its own
charm its own attractiveness the way
that loaves of bread split open on top
in the oven The Ridges are just
byproducts of the baking and yet
pleasing somehow they Rouse our appetite
without our knowing why or how ripe figs
begin to burst and olives on the point
of falling the shadow of Decay gives
them A peculiar Beauty stocks of wheat
bending under their own weight the
furrowed brow of the lion Flex of foam
on The Boar's mouth and other things if
you look at them in isolation there's
nothing beautiful about them and yet by
supplementing nature they enrich it and
draw Us in and anyone with a feeling for
nature um a deeper sensitivity will find
it all gives pleasure even what seems
inadvertent he'll find the jaws of live
animals as beautiful as painted ones or
sculpture he'll look calmly at the
distinct beauty of old age and men women
and at the loveliness of children and
other things like that will call out to
him constantly things un not by others
things seen only by those at home with
nature and its works so notice what he's
talking about here there's this
availability of beauty
everywhere we have to make ourselves
capable of grasping it we have to have
not just a deeper uh understanding but a
deeper the word there is anoon a common
uh concept that we can tap into as human
beings um a feeling a pathos we need as
well and notice there's you know nothing
in these things that is going to make us
that way it's up to us and how we look
at it so there's a passage I want to
bring up just to tie all of this
together and then we'll we'll jump into
some good discussion hopefully epicus as
you know wants us to be purple threads
he says I want to be the purple that
small and Brilliant portion which causes
the rest to appear comly and beautiful
what good does the purple do to the
Garment what to but to be beautiful in
itself and to set a good example to the
rest now you could interpret this as
well there's purple threads and that's
great and then there's the white garment
and that's all crap you know don't be a
white garment person but no it's a
cohesive hole it's not a contrast here
of good versus bad or wise versus stupid
or anything like that he is saying you
know you can be the purple thread and
then you provide a good example and you
beautify the rest and I want to say
although epicus doesn't say this maybe
we can think of the purple thread person
as also one who provides us with an
example for how to genuinely appreciate
the beauty that's out there waiting for
us to grasp it and respond to it in our
lives and so you know do we have
guidelines for this there there have
been a lot of that have been given I
think that are very helpful here and so
I'm just going to say three quick things
and then maybe others will have uh some
guidelines they want to bring up we do
need to direct ourselves towards the
right kinds of beauty and to be open to
recognizing them the beauty of the
cosmos the beauty in other people that
is not just of their faces or clothing
or uh bodies or things like that and we
also have to avoid certain mindsets that
I think are quite prevalent in our own
time that want to control or to consume
or to
commodify beauty and then the other
thing that we have to do
is extricate ourselves from excessive
and irrational responses to what we take
as beautiful and epicus gives us an
example of this in the enidan when he
says you see a beautiful body you've got
Temperance to help you deal with that
right you have the capacity to to do all
of these sorts of things so that is all
that I have for you I think I've taken
up a little bit more time than I was
supposed to so hopefully we'll have some
good
Q&A and uh we can uh maybe derive some
new guidelines as well oh that was so
wonderful okay can we do the clap in the
comments thing which is so cool and you
do have some
questions that was wonderful so um I I'm
just gonna start with the most recent is
there anything imaginary that is
beautiful to Classic
stoics oh um
imaginary yeah I mean so imaginary as in
not really existing I suppose you would
say say right so um yeah we could talk
about um narrative figures in in fiction
like in drama right and it's kind of
funny because in a lot of cases epic
tetus will say ah you know the Iliad
just a bunch of connected appearances
you know uh we look at these plays but I
mean you senica wrote plays so
presumably thought there was some value
there um and I I think you know we could
look at at fictional characters and at
things that they're going through and
say aha there's some there's some beauty
there perhaps Beauty in terms of virtue
or other things as well like we could
say the relationship between people of
say love could be beautiful right um you
think of a perseus's poem where he has
and I'm not counseling this as as a a
great example for all of us but KO and
his and his wife you know uh they've
been separated from each other but they
still love each other well there's a
kind of beauty there right right but KO
was a real person but perseus's KO is
not real KO it's it's an imagination so
maybe that would be um a great question
a great answer now the problem is we
have these amazing uh questions lining
up um do you think that the beauty of
virtue is one of the core Arguments for
why virtue is the only
good oh that's that is actually a great
question and I won't be able to explore
that fully but I mean do see in a lot of
stoic texts um you know think about
Marcus's
uh reminder to himself in the morning
right um the people who are screwed up
don't realize that the good is the
beautiful and so there's there's this
great overlap the the genuinely
beautiful and there is a beauty to
Virtue and it's got multiple affective
elements to it this is where like I
think it's senica's letter 120 when he's
talking about where did we get our ideas
of the virtues from can be quite helpful
and he says it's according to analogy
and what he means by analogy there is
something like a grasping a rudimentary
thing so we see somebody you know this
isn't what we see all the time but
there's this guy defending the bridge
against the enemy and he's displaying
this remarkable courage and we're like
holy crap look at that guy you know and
we we respond to it and we grasp the
virtues in that way and I think think
you know we we do have like definitions
of virtue but we really do need
instances and examples that you and I
can relate to as as human beings right
so that might you know that might play
into that well this is uh really hard
because there are a lot of good
questions up here and I think we have
time for one but one is uh related to
what you just described is there I mean
I think you said something like uh our
virtue does sometimes uh come out in um
um our physical did you say something
like that oh well no I I I mean it's we
do virtue through our bodies we could
say right and we can tell whether
somebody is
virtuous sometimes by what they say but
obviously if they just tell you well I'm
courageous that doesn't make them
courageous right um we see it in their
actions and the patterns of those those
actions and then the words that go along
with them and there has to be you know
kind of a a a consonance be between
those a consistency and that's how we
actually witness virtue um we we can't
ever like look inside with some sort of
ex-ray for moral purposes and find The
Virtue lurking in the heart or the the
head or whatever it happens to be um we
have to go by outward
appearances and I mean I don't even know
if we can like look inside ourselves
with the inner eye or whatever metaphor
we want to use and see The Virtue
shining within us I think we have to see
it in in what we do over and over and
over again and that's manifest in this
physical world that we exist in yeah so
it might not be physical Beauty in a
conventional sense that was the but but
maybe a stoic will see things other than
uh physical Beauty even if they're
observing the same behavior as as a non
stoic you know and just to before we
totally run out of time how you use
whatever measure of physical Beauty you
have could be how you demonstrate virtue
right are you like full of yourself and
expect people to um fall all over
themselves doing nice things for you if
you happen to be attractive for a little
while um well that would be unver
virtuous right uh be being attractive
and yet behaving like a decent human
being well that would be at least on the
way to Virtue so great thank you Greg
and Jennifer that was just amazing thank
you both big round of applause again in
the chat flood that chat with your
applause
emojis